the power the power is literally in your
hands
unlike any time in my career one state
one state can chart the course
not just for the next four years but for
the next generation
what is at stake here in georgia
simply put everything uh this is the
future of
the united states that is taking place
in
one portion of the country this is
these are two elections that are truly
going to define the presidency of joe
biden
and what legislation he his
administration will be able to pass
so maybe we start with georgia first
what what
do these uh elections mean for this
state
yeah so since 2002 georgia has been
a republican stronghold republicans have
succeeded in most every election
and since 2018 we've seen a change and
so for georgia
to be a place that is at the epicenter
of political change in the united states
it's unheard of and i think that that's
what makes this election
sort of unex extraordinarily unheard of
i think if it was in a state like
michigan
or um pennsylvania we would be
it would be different but especially
since it's georgia it is
i think it makes it all the more unique
so what
what made the big difference uh in the
last election which kind of
started this whole change or made this
whole change visible maybe you can talk
a little bit about that
yeah donald trump um
georgia atlanta is a growing
city in the united states it is you know
it's been called the hollywood of the
south it's the new business
empire in the country and
more and more people are moving to the
suburbs
and we have seen especially in 2018
as well as in this election that
suburban women have been
true the true change and people
in for example you know the suburbs are
highly educated
unlike the rest of the state um
there it's a wealthier portion and i
think that that's why
georgia is so unique that there is you
know 50
of the state lives in the metro area and
then 50
lives in rural communities
so maybe you can explain to our audience
a little bit the importance of
stacy abrams and why she became so
important and what she's doing and what
she's doing obviously so well
yeah you know regardless of what people
think of stacy abrams politically
you know she is a genius you know she
has been
able to go into communities especially
communities of color
as well as into um communities
like college campuses where young people
are she has encouraged
voter turnout and a lot of people look
at her election in 2018
and they see and they feel that she was
wronged in that election
she was denied the chance of being
governor
and i think that that lit a fire in
people
and it encouraged them to go out and
make a difference in these elections
because you know
in georgia we have seen that you know
the smallest number of people
can change an election entirely
yourself are a republican i used to be a
republican
but you are engaged in this group gop
the grand old party for joe how did this
come along
yeah you know i have been in a
republican family for
generations my great-grandmother
worked for republican president gerald
ford
um you know needless to say being a
republican
was a part of my day and
when donald trump came along you know he
claimed to be a republican and i saw
you know all of these things that he was
doing that you know just were
not what the party stood for you know
his
his disdain for immigrants women people
of color
and that's not what the party was about
so you know and i do
and i don't identify as a republican
anymore
they left me a long time ago
and so especially in this election you
know it was not
just about democrat or republican
it was about the type of country we
wanted to be
you know a country where people are
welcome or
a p a country where people are turned
away
tell us a little bit about um about that
what that
all means for your former party for the
republicans
you know i think it's sad and you know
i think that a lot of republicans who
are in my shoes
would agree with that i don't know if
the party
will ever be what it was i think that we
have seen in the past two elections
where more and more people who identify
with donald trump have been elected
we have seen 106 members of congress
and 11 u.s senators who in the last few
days have said that they are going
to challenge these election results on
the 6th
and they are denying 80 million
americans their voice
and you know this is an outgoing
president
he lost by a resounding margin he said
in 2016
it was a landslide so you know he had a
landslide defeat
this go-around and you know it has been
i mean it's shameful truly in what has
happened
and i think that for these republicans
to
go against the will of the party in the
in the country
it i don't think that the party will
ever go back to what it was at least for
the foreseeable future because many of
these
republicans are here to stay and what
about the republicans who kind of
are the traditional politicians you
joined or you wanted to kind of be part
of when you were a member of the
republican party
what will happen to to those people
you know i i think that they are a
a dying breed you know moderate
republicans who have been elected
are few and far between i would say
there are truly
three in in in the senate um
those being senators mark murkowski
collins and romney
um i don't know if there are many states
that today would elect a moderate
republican anymore
and you know we've seen just in the last
few days um
a former cabinet secretary and u.s
senator
who was a republican call for a new
party
to be formed and you know i
that i think that's more where we're
headed than seeing
the republican party go back to you know
the days of
lincoln and eisenhower so i
i think that that's more likely than a
new party form than
for a reformation in the
gop so uh
do i understand you're right you you see
the possibility that kind of the trump
style republicans
keep the old the good old party and like
the
rather moderate republicans are forced
to
uh to start a new party
yeah yeah you know i think that it's
hard for a lot of people
you know many of these republicans
like that the ones that i've mentioned
you know i think it's hard for them to
totally
jump [ __ ] and per se become a democrat
because
you know there is still ideological
difference between you know
mitt romney and someone like
kamala harris or joe biden you know
there are disagreements
and so i think that i
think that you know a lot so i think
that where i'm going with this is
there's a lot of everyday people
who struggle with that same decision
and i do believe that if a strong center
party
were to come about i think it could be
successful
especially with more and more
high-profile republicans
sort of endorsing this idea
and would you then consider to join this
party
yeah you know i i what i've learned more
in the last two elections for me
personally is that
it's become more about the person over
the party and what's right for the
country you know i
in this past election i voted for a few
republicans
and i voted for several democrats i
voted for
raphael warnock and john ossoff and
i think that that's more of what we need
i hope that you know
regardless of whether a new party comes
about or the two parties stay the way
they are
i hope that all americans whether you're
from the right
or the left you know can look more at
person rather than just sticking with
the status quo and what the party says
so caller when you said in the beginning
of our
little chat here everything is at stake
regarding the whole united states talk a
little bit about that what did you mean
by that
you know we have seen that in the last
few years that
obamacare the affordable care act needs
fixing we are in the middle of this
pandemic we need
economic relief and
you know why we are seeing more and more
calls around the country for
them to pass a 2 000 stimulus relief
for each american and
in without a senate that can
provide for joe biden's policies
i think that he's going to have his
administration
is going to have an incredibly difficult
time
you know trying to work with some of
these republicans who are there who have
been
staunch supporters of donald trump and
who
in recent days have
you know wanted to put a halt to
everything that they're more concerned
about supporting the ego
of the current man in the white house
rather than
supporting the lives of hundreds of
millions of americans
and what does it mean for the two-party
system
the outcome which which impact will that
have
on the future of the dams and the future
of the republicans
i mean i think that if the two democrats
are able to pull it off on tuesday i
think
that it shows that if you know again
like we talked about stacey abrams
techniques
i think it proves that you know it works
that you don't have to
pander to the center that you can you
know run on traditional democrat values
that you can make the case and you know
people agree
and and i think that if
for the republican party i think that it
proves
that everything is at stake in all of
these states that they once thought
were strongholds i mean you know arizona
now for the first time in decades has
two
democrat senators you know this is not
just something that's happening
in georgia but we're seeing it in other
places as well
and you know if the two republicans are
able to win
i think that it is a true major blow
to the democrat party and i think that
they are going to have to do
some major evaluation and i think that
it
and it's scary because it opens the door
for a lot of republicans to scream
that the 2020 election was just a huge
fraud in georgia so that's
that's how you think that they will be
kind of kind of interpreted or
that it might be used for that argument
again if the republicans win the senate
race yeah i mean you know joe biden
only won georgia by what like 13 000
votes
and so you know donald trump for the
last days has
you know screamed and basically called
for republicans not even to vote in
georgia because the whole election
is a fraud and you know he'll you know
if the two republicans win he'll
use that and say look i did win georgia
does donald trump help the two
democratic candidates
i think he does just as much good for
both side i think that donald trump does
something incredibly smart
in that you know he holds if you look
his rallies
all occur in parts of rural georgia he
turns out his voters in rural areas
which
as i mentioned before account for half
the population
you know and i but i also think that you
know donald trump
you know encourages democrats living in
atlanta
and the surrounding areas to get out
just as much i think
georgia is unlike the rest of the
country
i think that it's it's truly going to be
a game
of who can turn out who better
so carter i have to ask this last
questions
question what's your take who will win
if i was going to play it safe
i would say that david perdue the
republican will probably
will beat jon ossoff but i think that
raphael warnock will beat kelly lefler
and i think that there's a good chance
that we're going to see a democrat
republican
split victory and what would that mean
i think that it you know it sends a loud
message you know kelly lefler has
um been a conspiracy theorist
she has posed with
a a congresswoman elect who has
spread racist anti-semitic
anti-immigrant remarks and i think that
it also
proves that you know there is still
shrek there is a shred of decency
that is still accepted in politics and
i think that it proves that the
republican party
if they want to be successful they have
to
condemn these people like marjorie
greene
kelly lefler who continue to support
just absurd theories
thank you very much stay well and talk
to you soon
absolutely happy new year bye happy new
year
you